This video is brought to you by brilliance
problem-solving based website and app with a hands-on approach
Improve your STEM skills while having a great time learning a brilliant at org forward slash buyer. Graphics more on them in a bit
In the 125 years since Alfred Nobel's the state first established the Nobel Prize Cambridge University has had a
Remarkable group of laureates honored for their work their names a synonymous with excellence and innovation bertrand russell francis crick niels
Bohr milton friedman. There are literally a hundred more yet
Despite all those brilliant minds that have walked the cambridge grounds. Only one of them has ever won two Nobel prizes
He marched into an unknown branch of science which few even knew existed at the time and blazed a trail
For those who would come after him. He wildly expanded the definitions of what we knew about genetics and human existence
He kick-started a scientific revolution
that has raged well into the 21st century and incredibly he did all of that with the humility of a man who was just
tinkering with some toys in his garage
His name was Frederick Sanger and his brilliant career in biochemistry shaped the modern world
Frederick Sanger was born August the 13th 1918 in the village of Rend home in Gloucestershire, England
His father who was also named Frederick was a physician who had studied at st
John's College, Cambridge
Fred senior was something of an innovation himself long before his son started investigating peptide chains
he worked with Scotland Eon to develop a forensic test that could differentiate between human blood and
Animal blood more than a decade before he had any children Fred senior travelled to China as an Anglican medical missionary
he served a local community and a mission hospital spreading the gospel wherever he could but in 1912 with a country on the brink of
Revolution and Frederick in poor health. He returned to England to open his own practice
It was here that he met the love of his life Cecily crude sin in the most romantic way possible
He was called to treat her sceptic finger
They married in 1960 nestle gave birth to two sons theo and frederick over the next two years
fred senior and theo both had a tremendous impact on the direction of
Frederick sang as life theo loved nature and so he often brought along his younger brother for outdoor adventures and animal
Investigations the boys would hunt for newts in the family pond or scour
The yard for birds nests between his father the doctor and his brother the naturalist
frederick couldn't help but develop a scientific curiosity a thirst for
Discovering the nature of things whether they intended to or not
The elder men of his household pushed him towards rational investigation even at a young age
The other early influence on Frederick's life was religion
Although his father had left China as a Protestant by the time Theo and Frederick were running around the yard
The household had distinct Quaker influences Cecily's father was a wealthy cotton merchant and when he passed away
He left the sang as both money and religious reading material perhaps because of his time in China which featured simmering
revolutionary violence and distrust of Protestant missionaries Fred Xenia pounds the Quaker perspective appealing he converts it and in
1923 he moved the now family of five to tan worth in Arden near Birmingham to be close to a stronger Quaker community
Quaker beliefs colored most aspects of young Frederick's childhood he and his siblings were always taught to say their prayers
when they reached school age Frederick was tutored by a Quaker governess in
1927 at the age of nine Frederick was shipped off to boarding school his destination a Quaker school known then as downs preparatory school
He stayed there until 1932 when he began boarding at Bronston school in Dorset
It was a Bronston where sanga's Quaker roots were finally joined with his budding love
science
At Bronston Sanger began to flourish as a student of the sciences Branston operated on a less structured educational
system than many of its peer
Institutions at the time instead of crushing its pupils with structure and discipline the school allowed students to work on a more flexible schedule
Offering free periods and allowing the boys themselves to prioritize which subjects they wanted to focus on additionally
there was a new headmaster Thorold code who eliminated the popular practice of beating instead his
administration chose to emphasize growth through self-discipline
so while the school has a record of some boys taking advantage of their new freedom by
lollygagging around
Though shift away from teaching through violence was undoubtedly a boon to a young Quaker like Fred Sanger who began to prefer
the benefits of self-guided tinkering and experimentation Sanger reportedly enjoyed a good relationship with Frazer Highlands the
Branston biology master who would often take the boys out on adventures in nature
He got along even better with the chemistry master Henry Jeffery. Oddish a man who was an accomplished photographer
electrician and
motorcyclist he ran the chemistry lab, Bronston
Which he had personally renovated and wired inside a portion of an old stable sanga's
Quietly surging aptitude for the sciences propped up by brawn Stan's emphasis on self discipline and individual work put him on a trajectory
towards success at the time borders set to take and passed their school certificate to graduate and qualify for
University and Sanger spent so much time working and studying alongside
Highlands and oddish that he took and passed a certificate a year early as if that wasn't enough
he scored seven credits on his exam which was at the time the highest score in the history of the school while most of his
Peers were stressing over their own certificate
Sanger had a final year to
Tinker in the school laboratory x' and think about his future free of any pressure from exams
his father expected him to become a doctor and continued the Sanger family legacy and
With high test marks and natural aptitude for the sciences. This was arguably the most logical choice
Frederick considered his options during his free year while continuing to conduct experiments with oddish in the stable lab in
1936 he applied to some John's College at Cambridge
It was the natural choice for sang her as it was the very same school
Attended by his father his uncle and his most influential teacher with his strong test scores
His acceptance was all but a formality his choice of studies on the other hands
well that was quite up in the air Frederick arrived at the conclusion that his father's career while rewarding
Would not enable him the sort of intellectual freedom. He had grown accustomed to in his formative years
His father was always running around checking on patients serving the community to him that sounded burdensome as he had throughout his childhood
Frederick the younger wanted to explore so when he arrived at Cambridge
He placed himself in a natural sciences course track studying chemistry physics and maths
he found himself intrigued with the ideas of
Ernest Baldwin one of his university teachers who proposed that solving certain mysteries in the world of chemistry might unlock new understanding of
biological systems as Sanger marched through his university education
He continued to gravitate toward the emerging field of biochemistry
Prior to the 20th century science and technology hadn't yet advanced far enough the mankind, really?
understands the extent of the relationship between
biology and chemistry
but by the late 1930s
Sanger and his Mendes were beginning to inch towards a complete understanding of the living world by the time he completed his bachelor's degree in
1939 though
Biochemistry it wasn't the only thing inching closer towards Frederick Sanger
Europe had become embroiled in World War two and
Scientists and science departments everywhere were turning their focus away from lab
experiments towards the growing axis threat in Europe Sanger was no stranger to the Nazis during his free year at
Bronston he had spent a few weeks at a partner boarding school called shul
Slalom in southern Germany as part of an exchange program. He saw firsthand zel
German students were told to open their day with prayers then follow them with a reading from mind cup his religious
sensibilities found this juxtaposition
To be quite shocking as a Quaker though. His position on war was clear
he had affirmed his religious upbringing at university by becoming a member of the peace pledge Union and
associated with an anti-war group within Cambridge's family of scientists
So when Britain declared war on Germany in 1939 Sanger wasn't just avoiding conflict
He was a true well, established pacifist and yet their receipts to prove it after appearing before a military tribunal
He was granted conscientious objector status even if Sanger wasn't going to war though
The war was gonna come to him after taking an extra biochemistry class at Cambridge
He was temporarily dispatched to Winfred hospital in 1940 to help staff a war hospital as an orderly after a few months
He was able to return to Cambridge where he began gearing up for his PhD
Sanger hunkered down in his beloved biochemistry department partnering up with
Albert inure burger or as his mentor together the power undertook a study that focused on two fascinating subjects lysine
Metabolism and the nitrogen content of a potato now
I realize that no one comes to buy a graphics for our expert analysis of protein synthesis
But I'll try and do my very best to at least nod in the direction of sang as thesis work
Lysine is one of nine essential amino acids. Meaning it's required for human function
But it isn't efficiently produced in the human body in mass quantities other words
This means that it's something we have to incorporate into our diets in the case of lysine
it's often consumed via meat eggs beans or lentils and the body uses it to synthesize key proteins Sanger tried to
Unravel the nature of lysine metabolism in a complex series of experiments centered around feeding it to rats his experiments were inconclusive
The scientific community didn't know enough about amino acids or proteins at that point and it would be another 30 years before
Biochemists would unlock the lysine mystery but Sanger nonetheless received credit for his thesis
This was called the metabolism of the amino acid lysine in the animal body
He defended his work to Charles Harrington and Albert Charles Chibnall in
receiving his PhD
At the age of 26 at the same time. He was crafting his thesis
He and Yerger began a separate experiment aimed at aiding the war effort and it examines
variation in nitrogen levels for different types of domestic potatoes Sanger eventually describes the potato
Experiment as one that was completed for more practical problems
The paper was published in biochemical journal in septum 19:42
Now you might not be studying potatoes or in a lab at Cambridge
But you can still learn more about science through today's sponsored brilliance
Brilliant is a problem-solving based website and with a hands-on approach
They've got over 60 interactive courses in math science and computer science
They've heard me talk about brilliant before and whether you're a student looking to get ahead or a professional keen on building some skills
You should definitely check them out now. Maybe you've wanted to learn about neural networks
essentially how computers can
program themselves
Well brilliant have a course all about that and it teaches you this through easy to access puzzles
And it does it in plain English
there's no reading a paragraph a dozen times and then still being like
What can I get it not with brilliance and that's just one example, there's loads of great stuff on their platform including daily challenges
Which are a great way to flex your gray matter
Every day look brilliant is a great complement to watching videos like this one and they'll really help you develop and master
even complex technical subjects
So if you want to support biographic sans get unlimited access to all of brilliance in depth maths and science courses
Please head over to brilliant a dork forward slash buyer graphics to get 20% off their annual
Premium subscription and let's get back into it
As if saying it didn't have enough going on in his life while he was earning degrees writing thesis 'iz and supporting war hospitals
He was also falling in love Sanger had met Joan Margaret Howe through an anti-war group while pursuing his
Bachelor's at Cambridge while he was tolling west and John's College. Joan was a Leicester transplant studying economics
They grew close when Sanger lost both of his parents within a year of each other halfway through undergrad
They were married soon after the war started on December 28 1940 at st
Mary's Church inside later as he was preparing to defend his doctorate in 1943
He and Joan were also preparing to welcome their first child Robin into the world
1943 is when it all changed for Sanger. It wasn't just the baby or the PhD
He also began to earn money as a professional scientist up until that point Sanger had enjoyed a comfortable life as a student
thanks to his family's wealth and
Eventually, the inheritance bequeathed from his parents finally in 1943 Sanger began drawing a real salary
Thanks to the Beit Memorial Fellowship for medical research which subsidized sang US research into the 1950s
With his PhD firmly in hand Sanger turned around and began working with the same man who'd signed off on his doctorate
newly minted Cambridge biochemistry professor
A/c Chibnall Jim Knowles a research group at Cambridge was one of the foremost groups of experts on protein chemistry in the world
And they were determined to crack the mysteries behind how proteins did what they did. Not all
scientists at the time even believed proteins could be mapped or studied but Chibnall believed that they could
thus his team got to work the team had already been studying insulin when Sanger joined the group so he assigned himself the task of
Isolating and identifying the free amino groups of insulin through trial and error Assange had developed a method using a chemical called Dyne nitro Fleury
Benzene which was a molecule specifically crafted to break ins gilland down into smaller chains of amino
Acids once he had broken it down into smaller pieces
He began using a brand new cutting-edge technique called partition chromatography
To break down the amino acid chains even further Sanger was eventually left with just two sets of terminal amino groups
Phenylalanine and glycine which suggested to our brilliant scientist that insulin is the product of two separate amino acids
Okay now unless you're an actual
Biochemist, there's a chance that you don't have the first idea of what any of that meant and that's okay
I'm sure your sharpest attack and
Whatever it is you do for a living all you really need to know about our boy Frederick here. Is that with careful?
experimentation over the course of a decade
He went farther in his understanding of basic protein structure than any
Human ever had before and he accomplished it all simply by doing what he did best
Standing at his workbench tinkering with science by the time Sanger had established he knew for sure that insulin had two distinct
unchanging peptide chains
He had already shocked the scientific world at the time which was only 75 years ago
The scientific community had yet to prove that proteins were made up of specific
Sequences and not randomized or ever-changing amino groups by the 1950s. He attracted other scientists Dallben completely mapped the entire
Insulin protein again Sanger recognized the usefulness of new applications like paper chromatography and acid
Hydrolysis and used these modern allowances to his advantage Heep honored with Australian
Biochemist EAP Thompson to fully map insulins a chain that ends in glycine similarly
He partnered with Austrian hands Tuppy to map the B phenylalanine chain
This was the first time anyone had ever mapped a full protein completely redefining modern Sciences vision of what?
Biochemists could uncover. I mean I didn't have any sort of grand ideas like sitting down and saying I'm going to
Sequence a whole protein or anything like that
I mean that makes me good story by 1958 Fredrick saying as world had evolved quite a bit in the 15 years since his PhD
Joan had given birth again to a son named Peter in
1946 the Medical Research Council had offered him a paid research position in 1951 Archer Martin and Richard singe the inventors of partition chromatography
At won the 1952 Nobel Prize in Chemistry died nitro fluorobenzene
The original chemical that Frederick used to break up insulin had been christened
Sanghas reagent then finally in 1958 the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences made official what everyone in the community?
seemed to already know for revealing the full sequence of a protein and
Revolutionising the human knowledge of proteins and their peptide chains Frederick Sanger was awarded the Nobel Prize for chemistry
Sanger wasn't done yet, though
if anything his first Nobel validated his
exploratory approach Sanger wrote to his colleagues years later saying that the 1958 prize had an important and
stimulating effect on my subsequent career
I had remained in Cambridge concentrating only on basic research and avoiding as far as possible teaching or
Administrative responsibilities this recognition of my work gave me renewed confidence and enthusiasm to continue in this way of life
Which I enjoyed
Sanga's insolent revelations had sent quakes through the adolescent biochemistry field
but ask any Brit amount the revolution of the
1960s and they'll probably tell you everything you wanted to know about John Lennon or Roger Daltrey
But quietly while the kinks were ripping fresh chords in North London
The molecular revolution was well underway inside the halls of Cambridge laboratories two years after his final child
Sally was born in 1960 Sanger moved into the Medical Research. Council's swanky new Cambridge facility the laboratory of molecular biology
Sanger for his part was the head of the protein division
But he was hardly the only big name in the building just a few years before cream formed in 1966
Cambridge was putting together a supergroup of their very own Sanger
Aaron klug Max Perutz John Kendrew and Francis Crick all began working out of the LMB
building and they had an unreal opening salvo parrots and Kendra won the 1962 Nobel Prize for chemistry by
expanding on sanga's earlier work studying the structures of globular proteins Crick one and even more high-profile Nobel in
1962 as he and American partner James Watson uncovered the double helix structure of DNA
Winning the Nobel Prize for Physiology and medicine the lab holes in the LMB were absolutely booming cranking out new
revelations about the nature of life
Faster than the scientific community could process them after Watson and Crick's DNA
Projection much of the team's focus moved from amino acids and proteins to nucleic acids and genetic material
With all the discovery going on around him Sanger began to feel his interests pulling in a new direction
Just as he had spent hours tinkering around unraveling the secrets of proteins
He now wanted to investigate the nature of nucleic acids Sanger viewed an investigation into genetics as the natural evolution of his
investigation into proteins
he spent much of the
1960s Sony sequencing messenger RNA which in case you've forgotten you're Health Sciences from primary school is sort of like
DNA's little brother that helps synthesize new proteins in the 1960s Sanger and his peers didn't really know that though
Which was why there was such a push to study nucleic acids in the first place by the early 1970s several
biochemists around the world had used in vitro protein synthesis to reverse-engineer how proteins developed on
Nucleotides and sanga's completed sequences helped confirm the first round of RNA
Hypotheses with RNA now at least partially unlocked Sanger wanted to move on to studying the white whale of the late 20th century
Genomics mapping and DNA despite three decades of Sanger pioneering these signs of organic sequencing
No, one had really attempted to map human DNA and there was a very good reason for this DNA strands
Even the nonhumans a massive we're talking about thousands of nucleotides for bacteria
millions for most complex organisms and billions for primates
so before we could even think about
Sequencing anything Frederick Sanger had to do what he did best play around in his lab and invent some brand new
Scientific methodology by 1975 Sanger had the beginnings of a plan. He began using a manipulated nucleotide called a dideoxy
nucleotide to chop down DNA strands into pieces
There were a few hundred nucleotides long rather than tens of thousands the deoxy had a similar chemical structure to a regular
Nucleotide but with one key difference, it could peel chains off separating them from the rest of the double helix
If Sanger repeated the process enough times
He could sequence an entire organisms DNA and that was exactly what he did slowly but surely
he completed the mapping out of five thousand three hundred and seventy-five nucleotides of
bacteriophage phi x one seven four in
1977 it was the first DNA genome to ever be sequenced. Once again Sanger had embarked on a 15 years scientific Odyssey
Starting with Watson and Crick's double helix discovery back in 1962 that culminated in a seminal moments in human
Scientific discovery sacrifice 174 genome had virtually no practical application
But it did represent a gateway to the idea that human genetics could realistically be sequenced and studied the first team through the Gateway
Unsurprisingly was sang as cambridge gang after successfully tackling a bacterial genome
They moved on to map the 16,000 nucleotides in human
DNA and the 48,000 nucleotides in bacteria phage lambda
finishing those projects over the next few years by 1980 the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences was ready to place sanga's name an
Incredibly rare heir for massive contributions to the booming scientific field of DNA sequencing the 1980
Nobel prize for chemistry was awarded to Sanger and his sequencing partner Walter Gilbert for their work with nucleotide bases
American biochemist Paul Berg received credit on the award as well for his parallel work on nucleotides and
Recombinant DNA this was an unprecedented move from the Nobel Committee as only four individuals had ever won multiple
Nobles Marie Curie for physics and chemistry John Bardeen twice for physics and Linus Pauling for chemistry and Peace
Sanger that became the fourth and final member of the exclusive
multiple Nobel Club
It's a fitting honor for a man who approached his research with a quiet
relentless dignity during his 1980 noble speech Sanger explained
I believe that we have been doing this not primarily to achieve riches or even honor but rather because we were interested in the work
Enjoyed doing it and felt very strongly that it was worthwhile
it was a classic line from a classic scientist one who knew even from an early age that
Playing around at a lab bench was its own reward?
Fred sanger retired in 1983
Just three years after his second Nobel Prize 40 years of revolutionary lab work had been enough him
He wanted to go home spend time with his wife and grandchildren and work in his garden
Sanger remained disarmingly humble about his career which by all accounts was filled with revolutionary
discoveries and near superhuman levels of persistence beyond his to Nobles
He was elected a member of the Royal Society in 1954 Rhodes Order of the Companions of honour in 1981
He was named a commander of the Order of the British Empire awarded the Copley medal and the order of merit
Oh and in 1993 when the British Medical Research Center moved to establish a genome research centre
they named it the Sanger Institute all this from a man who fondly referred to his career as
Just a chap messing about in a lab Sanger did enjoy working on projects
Which is partially why he began looking forward to his retirement so much. He wanted to swap his beakers for a boat
And so he did quietly spending the final three decades of his life enjoying time with his family
growing plants in his garden and by his own words
messing about in boats
Tanga lives a long and full life enjoying plenty of time with his grandchildren and eventually seeing his work with DNA sequencing fully realized
twenty years after his retirement in 2003 an
Extraordinary international team of scientists completed their work on the human genome having completely mapped out every nucleotide
responsible for human genetics and it all started
decades earlier with Sanger a Cambridge laboratory and an insatiable curiosity for knowledge
Sang, his wife Joan died in 2012 and Sanger passed away the following year on November the 19th
2013 he was 95 the world mourns a Titan of 20th century science the New York Times
Labeled him a genetic pioneer while Scientific American crowns him the father of DNA sequencing
It's an appropriate title for a man whose influence reverberates throughout the history of science Tseng has worked with proteins ignited a revolution
so vast we still haven't fully completed the results nearly 75 years down the road his
1977 DNA paper on the dideoxy
sequencing method also called the Sanger method has been formally cited by other scientific publications more than
73,000 times the Cambridge laboratory for molecular
Biology has continued to churn out Nobel laureates
The British press actually refers to it as the noble Factory
But even there no one has equalled Frederick Sanger achievements his astounding life of peerless achievement leaves us all with a critical question
of self-examination
If we all sat down with a goal in mind and messed about until we got it, right? What could we accomplish?
So I really hope you found that video interesting
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below
also
If this is inspired you why not check out our fantastic science-based sponsor brilliants who i'm gonna link to below and thank you for watching